but miss a movie over
Point Break
so this Point Break is a remake of the
original Point Break with Patrick Swayze
and Keanu Reeves kind of and in Point
Break there's this group of guys are
committing these crimes or extreme
athletes their adrenaline junkies Johnny
Utah he's new to the FBI and he was like
oh hey I kind of think like them I'm
gonna infiltrate their gang I'm gonna
bring them in so now we have the more
boring attempt at Point Break now I
don't always like comparing the remake
to the original but I'm going to do it
in this one in the sense that at my
fingertips I can reference the original
and be like see they did something
better in there that this one just
didn't do but rest assured where this
movie fails is as a movie in and of
itself not as a remake not compared to
the original all right that out of the
way let's get to it or I'm gonna list
off what I liked about this movie
because I'm coming off of Christmas
still feeling positive I want to feel
some Christmas spirit when I have a
little bit of optimism left in here so
let's talk about it what I liked with
the extreme sports I mean when there's
skiing down the mountains when they're
climbing the cliff there's this one
rock climbing segment that was actually
I was like wow everyone's dangling at
the fingertips it looks like they could
fall at any moment I feel like someone
could die and the surfing was really
cool I mean the cameras in the tube with
her it was like always like you're
surfing how cool is that does the
marriage of GoPro and YouTube allow us
to see that stuff online right now at
our fingertips every day all day yes so
is that a valid reason to say this
movies interesting at all oh right where
does this movie fail everywhere else
what I mean by everywhere else is all
right the people in this movie they just
don't interest me they bored me I wasn't
interested with Johnny Utah I wasn't
interested with the FBI it's really
funny because Ray Winstone in this movie
he has this line he says that Johnny
Utah he's like so told you - GFB line
sometimes it's downright boring I was
like great there are Oscar bait movies
that come around most every year if not
every other year that try to illustrate
that to us can we save it for that not
Point Break it's a movie about extreme
athletes who commit crimes where this
dude who's also an extreme athlete who
happens to work for the FBI infiltrates
their gang extreme this should be fun
that's what the other movie did right
that this just did wrong the original
Point Break kept it simple boudin his
crew or a budget hey dude it's like a
bunch of Michelangelo's from Ninja
Turtles who serve - happy
to rob banks probably for the simplest
reason ever because they liked money
this movie tries to make Bodie and his
crew like they're out there doing this
eight-point checklist tacked on to
crimes for a spiritual experience so at
that point they're almost like this
religious group they believe what
they're doing is the best thing for the
earth and themselves at a spiritual
level this movie just overreach mess
proof that more isn't better you have
more locations they're doing it for a
spiritual reason all the other movie now
that's small potatoes is just like it
takes place on one Beach and they're
robbing banks just because they rob
banks because it's fun and they like
money yeah that's just more interesting
than this movie where you tried to make
it bigger but you altima took bodis
group and turned them into a bunch of
Vulcans I don't care about this is the
classic case of the remake that tries to
make it darker and grittier but in doing
that it just lost all of the fun I was
bored shitless in a movie about extreme
sports and crime how in the end Point
Break is a pretty shitty Christmas gift
if he asked me the characters were
boring the crew was boring I wasn't
interested in anything I wasn't
interested in the stakes they had in
this movie the extreme sports stuff did
entertain me as I was watching it but as
proof positive that bigger isn't better
and above all else don't be afraid to
have fun in a movie that should be fun I
will say Point Break you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus one day
all right so Point Break have you seen
it what did you have not seen this so
what is your favorite movie revolving
around extreme sports whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more